the the broader question here is um
given how busy you are given how much
stuff you have going on in your life oh
what's
um
what's like the perfect exercise regimen
for you
to uh to keep yourself happy
to uh keep yourself productive in your
main line of work
yeah so I mean I've right now I'm
focused most of my workouts on on
fighting so so Jiu Jitsu and MMA
um but
I don't know I mean maybe if you're a
professional you can do that every day I
can't I just get you know it's too many
too many bruises and things that you
need to recover from so I do that you
know three to four times a week and then
um and then the other day is
um I just try to do a mix of things like
just cardio conditioning strength
building Mobility
um so you try to do something physical
every day yeah I try to unless I'm just
so tired that I just need to
need to relax but then I'll still try to
like go for a walk or something I mean
even here
um I don't know have you been on the
roof here yet no we'll go on the roof
after things but it's like we designed
this this building and I put a park on
the on the roof so that way that's like
my meetings when I'm just doing kind of
a one-on-one or talking to a couple of
people I'm I I have a very hard time
just sitting I feel like it gets super
stiff it like feels really bad
um
but I don't know I being physical is
very important to me I think it's um I
do not believe this gets to the question
about AI
I don't think that a being is just a
mind
um and I think we're we're kind of meant
to
do things and like physically and and a
lot of the sensations that we feel are
um are are connected to that and I think
that that's a lot of what makes you a
human is is basically you know having
those
having you know that set of Sensations
and
experiences around that
coupled with a mind to reason about them
um but I don't know I I think it's
important for balance to
to kind of get out challenge yourself in
different ways learn different skills
clear your mind